revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 hoy viernes nos acompaña en
nuestro estudio Rosa Pérez Macedo rosa
muy buena mañana vamos a empezar esta
revista de prensa con la situación en
Perú que destacada en el periódico el
país las protestas se intensifican el
gobierno se atrinchera así lo titula
Rosa exactamente Buenos días Raúl Este
es un artículo de Renzo Gómez periodista
peruano que señala que por primera vez
desde la destitución y el
encarcelamiento preventivo de Castillo
la movilización masiva se desplazó desde
el sur del país desde las zonas Rurales
a la capital a Lima y que precisamente a
diferencia de las regiones de la Sierra
Sur en la capital la policía no empleó
armas letales mientras en juliaca
escenario no de las protestas durante
todas estas semanas moría un ciudadano
que había quedado herido la noche
anterior al recibir un disparo de arma
de fuego y en Arequipa murió la víctima
55 del conflicto un hombre de 30 años
que recibió una letal en el abdomen
señala también a que la primera ministra
Dina boluarte lejos ha de empatizar con
el movimiento ciudadano que pide su
dimisión
demonizó satanizó no las protestas al
remarcar que se trata de unos ciudadanos
malos ciudadanos concretamente que
intentan perturbar alterar el estado de
derecho y aseguró que el gobierno se
mantiene firme vamos a cambiar de tema
ahora Rosa vamos a Estados Unidos con
una comparación entre los escándalos de
el expresidente Donald Trump y el actual
mandatario por la posición de estos
documentos o confidenciales lo cuenta de
Garden exactamente señala este texto que
si bien a primera vista parece que ambos
mandatarios ayana cometido errores de
manejo de documentos gubernamentales
parecidos los dos casos difieren
bastante y de Guardian nos muestra las
principales diferencias con una tabla
que vamos a ver aquí a continuación en
que señala los puntos no en los que
difieren Pues a la situación
el actual mandatario Joe biden y del
expresidente Donald Trump por un lado
Cuántos documentos se encontraron en
cada casa en cada caso en el caso de
Trump se trataría de más de 11.000
documentos entre los cuales unos 300
estaban
clasificados etiquetados como
confidenciales o incluso top Secret y
entre los cuales supuestamente habría
información de las capacidades militares
y nucleares de una potencia extranjera
en el caso de biden se trataría de menos
de 12 documentos según las fuentes
conocedoras del caso y no se sabe
exactamente que contienen por ahora cómo
se encontraron esta también es una gran
diferencia entre los dos casos en la
situación de Trump lo que pasó es que el
archivo Nacional de Estados Unidos se
dio cuenta Raúl que faltaban registros y
pidió al expresidente que devolviera
ciertos papeles recordemos que él se
negó Y entonces el FBI organizó una
redada en la mansión del ex mandatario
en mara lago y finalmente así obtuvo los
documentos en el caso de biden su equipo
los encontró en el pendvadens en
Washington y los entregó voluntariamente
a las autoridades para finalizar con el
resumen de estas diferencias Qué cargos
podrían pesar sobre cada uno de ellos En
el caso de Trump podría ser finalmente
acusado de obstrucción a la justicia y
el fiscal especial que Investiga también
la cuestión está investigando pues una
mala gestión voluntaria de secretos
gubernamentales en el caso de biden el
actual mandatario cuenta con que
normalmente el departamento de Justicia
no acusa formalmente al presidente en el
cargo y de momento tampoco hay evidencia
de que biden supiera de la localización
de estos documentos en el pent byden
Center bueno Rosa hasta aquí ese tema y
vamos a cerrar nuestra revista de prensa
del día de hoy con un texto del medio
independiente ruso que plantea este
medio quien va ganando la guerra de los
memes estoy refiriéndose al meme como un
arma de propaganda política
efectivamente Y esta es una entrevista a
verena straut quien es historiadora
Investiga particularmente sobre memes en
la universidad alemana de dresden ella
señala que el humor contenido en los
memes puede ser un mecanismo para
superar realidades políticas difíciles
particularmente pone un ejemplo alejado
de la guerra en Ucrania un ejemplo de
2011 que vamos a ver a continuación con
el movimiento de okupae Wall Street de
los indignados etcétera no hay un caso
que es el meme del policía rociando gas
pimienta con indiferencia este que vemos
aquí que explica muy bien Cuál es la
función de los memes en este caso al
cambiarlo de contexto no subrayamos lo
absurdo de la situación y el desdén con
el que una policía está aplicando esta
violencia sobre los ciudadanos en otros
contextos es también una forma de
esquivar la censura como vamos a ver a
continuación en unos memes donde unos
ataques son sustituidos por patitos de
goma en la plaza de tianan men no por
otro lado en algunos ejemplos como
señala la investigadora no es necesario
ni siquiera hacer Photoshop y cambiar al
digamos los memes de situaciones sino
que con la propia fotografía del momento
ya se genera esta situación de parodia y
pone el caso que todos recordaremos de
la larga mesa que separaba a Vladimir
Putin y a Emanuel macron en febrero no
del año pasado que también se convirtió
en objeto de parodia No a lo largo y
ancho de el espacio virtual bien en este
caso la investigadora señala
particularmente la función de una
estructura de un movimiento que se llama
North Atlantic feels organization un
poco una modificación de las siglas nato
recordemos otan en inglés que es una
movimiento de memes de apoyo al ejército
ucraniano frente a la invasión rusa en
este caso dos memes que han saltado
muchísimo digamos Pues en muchísimos
espacios virtuales los memes muy
populares son por un lado el perrito
shiba inu tú lo reconoces Raúl incluso
digamos que aquí lo estamos viendo no es
un perrito que aparece como un soldado
adorable no ucraniano un miembro más y
que ridiculiza en cierto modo la velia
la bélica y la épica no de La retórica
rusa de la propaganda de guerra incluso
del Ministerio de defensa ucraniano les
reconoció les dio las gracias por esta
labor de dinamitar llegamos a la
propaganda del ejército Ruso y por
último ya también está Santa javelina
veamos no sé si lo podemos ver a
continuación En todo caso es esta virgen
que aguanta aquí la ve Ah no bueno
si ustedes la quieran Buscar por
internet que aguanta un misil
antitanques no estadounidense y
finalmente Pues que da esta imagen a Tan
completa de La idiosincrasia digamos
ucraniana en estos momentos Rosa como
siempre Muchísimas gracias por esta
revista de prensa luego nos veremos
Gracias Rosa